dans ce métier on peut finalement
s'aimer encore défaut page mais
maintenant on dit toujours aviez-vous
très peu pour ça je rentre les fonds de
légende il quitta t'es con entretien
pourquoi d'ailleurs parce que je vois
pas quelle est la différence
non je pense qu'il n'y a pas à mes yeux
du père mais je parle de minutes ou non
le droit mais je vais te contredis alors
qu'il prend tout ton temps parce que je
veux dire le contraire
c'est la fameuse tête de ventura la
sous-marque l'expression qu'il a eu un
bras de ce que je vais lui répondre
laissez les biens alimentaires partout
c'est ça dans la rue personne tellement
arménien
je voulais dire henry dit peu mais est
ce que vous pouvez me citer alors une
copa si on quelconque ou quelqu'un peut
dire dans ce métier on a beaucoup d'amis
demandé au professeur à la faculté de
médecine interne
je vois pas je vois pas quelle est la
différence sont aussi donnés et les
hommes politiques
quand même une différence et il ya quand
même la lutte et - après moins
difficiles qu'elles luttent lanaudois
prod lui a pas de lutte c 'est durable
je peux dire les gens on a envie animal
et puis il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
la même envie de faire ce métier
donc il est évident que les peaux de
banane ne semble plus fréquente alors au
spectacle
suite moi comment on peut le faire on
comprend pas très bien votre
raisonnement allumiez pas prêt il a
qu'une seule chose je pense qui est
symptomatique dans certains cas et que
je trouve de stupidité absolument
impensable et inexcusable c'est ce que
j'ai entendu plusieurs fois que ça
consiste en quoi ça consiste de se
délecter d'un un succès d'un ami je veux
dire en pensant que peut-être que toi
seul tes succès à toi mon fils comme
cinéma va marcher il faut penser que
c'est le succès de tout le monde qui
vous fera marcher le cinéma et je ne
vois pas quelle est cette réaction de se
réjouir d'un succès j'en avais je veux
dire que ça moi c'est ça qui m'attriste
et les six attaques je veux arriver donc
tu viens tu pas du tout tu voulais pas
et c'est parce que telle
mais t'as pas été drôle et depuis qu'on
est atteint c'est nous qui pourront pas
en face de moi raison kabala on tient le
coup
alors oui déjà non à se taire oui bah
oui mais je vais prendre le relais oui
mais après oh oui le seul regret que
j'ai le seul ch ou et tuer mais avec ce
regret c'est que comment se fait-il que
lorsque vous allez aux états unis vous
voyez tous les metteurs en scène mais
faisant des cinémas tout à fait
différents les uns des autres les uns
faisant un cinéma un peu plus ambitieux
les autres cinéma - dunk mais ils font
partie d'une famille je ne dis pas que
ce sont des amis intimes mais tout ce
monde là seront se voit recevoir
je parle avec beaucoup de jeunes hommes
et de céret de toros coûte 700 en france
et lâche nous avons des clans qui je
vais même jusqu'à vous dire qu'il ne
salue pas si vous passez à côté on a
envie de dire mais pauvre imbécile
nous faisons partie de la même famille
as tu te devais aller à te ferais je
n'ai jamais demandé on m'a paru en bonne
forme
et un bravo je viens de jouer simplement
parce que nous avons il est superbement
invité par notre hôte gérard oury et il
était nous vous savez que quand nous
faisons un film nous mettons toujours au
générique tous ceux qui ont participé au
fil je ne voyais pas pourquoi ce soir
nous ne mettrions pas à l'honneur ceux
qui ont participé à ce dîner c'était
délicieux j'ai quand même vous raconter
une petite anecdote qui m'est arrivé
avec
monsieur était au bout là bas la légère
le recteur l'artiste
il y aurait un temps où je tournais à
paris en été
avec jean jabal
et tous les soirs ont dîné ici parce que
nous n y avait pas grand monde et
ondines et là après le tournage du film
à tous les soirs c'était l'été et beauté
magnifique
et un soir on était en train de miner
tous les deux et qui est ce qu'on voit
arriver
monsieur blier qui nous voit et
ensuite tu la devine on s'assoit tous
les trois la même table et on commence à
manger et à cette époque là j'aime
autant dire qu'elle tenait mieux
atypique à cheval tous les trois ans
c'était sérieux et évidemment de quoi
parlons nous en mangeant mois
entre intellectuels voir ce que ça
donnait on a commencé par des recettes
de cuisine et patati et patata et des
adresses et à la fin du repas et et dieu
sait susciter enfin celui ci dit
je viens de découvrir une ambiance
fabuleuse ah bon fait vieux et c'est
quoi
l'autre il avait les larmes aux yeux en
parlant il était comme ça ils n'en
pouvaient plus des milliers un trop tôt
feu
et ses attentes et ses excès et le
nord et on peignait ce pot-au-feu toi
bon je vais raccourcir l'histoire je te
donne ma parole d'honneur alain
guillaume effet atteint non il nous a
sauvé la vie je l'aurais pas là ils se
sont levés de table et il a le langage
chambre a dit on y va j'ai dit ça c'est
pas possible on va demain on va mourir
année on va casser je leur ai sauvé la
vie car à 11 heures du soir prenez la
voiture va bouffer en photo foule à la
gare du nord
[Musique]